Safiya clapped her hands and 20 flying
men appeared at her side, each
well-trained in the art of combat.
Now, ever since I was little, I wanted
to be Safiya. Unfortunately, Magic the
Gathering designers don't understand
balancing. Well-trained in the art of
combat, one, one. Like, come on, this
blade alone should be a two-one. And
they're just awful in any format, not
even pickable in draft. But today, we
are dusting them off with a hidden gem
of a commander, $90, 30 flying men, and
a the dream. We're taking them all the
way to bracket four. Now, what gives me
the courage, you ask? It's none other
than the very important character from
the Avatar series, and one of the top
2,000 crap, top 3,000 commanders, the
blue spirit. So, here's the deal with
the blue spirit. We are able to flash in
a flyer every turn and draw up to four
cards per round. As soon as we untap
with the blue spirit, we're mostly
operating at instant speed. We swarm the
board and annoy our opponents to death,
basically. So, why don't we meet our
flying men? Cloud Pirates, flying.
Zephyr Sprite, flying. Cloud Sprite,
flying with downside. Okay, but please
don't leave. A few of these here are
actually worth mentioning. Our main man,
of course, from the Arabian Nights set,
but aside from that, the best one here
is probably Siren Stormtamer. It's a
flyer, but also protection for our
commander. Doesn't get much better than
that. Alongside Stormtamer, we have
Flutterwing Nuisance. Seeing one of
these in the opening hand and we're in
for a good game. And quite a distance
behind is these with their menacing
abilities, which can be relevant. The
Spectral Sailor and the others with
flash are also particularly good as they
can bypass the one per turn limit on the
blue spirit. Also, we have a bit of an
impostor here in Signal Pest. It's close
enough to a flyer, but also serves as an
anthem for the entire team. Probably
worth a slot. The rest of these have,
um, cool art, I guess. Also, after some
success with the deck, I decided to swap
out a random one-one for a foil version
of this card. Yeah, I heard this card is
a sign of respect in the Magic
community. So, if people lose to it,
they're not as salty, which is nice. We
are all about respect over here. We do
need some ramp as a four-drop commander
that doesn't do anything on its own is a
bit slow. Getting it out with some mana
to spare would be ideal. But yeah, as a
deck with tunnel vision focus and not
too many backup plans, we have to go
fast. Aside from the most efficient ones
within our budget, we're also playing
these creatures. They pull double duty.
Yeah, let's be honest, the average card
quality here is not amazing, so we're
pretty dependent on the commander, but
luckily there's a bunch of backup
options. Starting with Coastal Piracy,
but they've made a ton of upgrades and
some of them are pretty excellent. I
mean, this cat, for example, is just
ridiculously pushed. Like, during
combat, we can flash it in to draw a
card already and then draw more once we
hit. The ship is also pretty sweet. A
Reconnaissance Mission, the cycling is
sweet, but we're probably never going to
cycle it. I've done it once, I think, to
dig for a board wipe that I I didn't
have in the deck. Oh, and there's these
two. They're not really upgrades, but
they do some pretty interesting stuff,
so we put them in. And now look at us.
We have a bunch of one-ones, which will
bring us cards, more mana, more cards,
more one-ones. Now, poking with flying
men is definitely annoying, but it's not
going to win us games. So, we do need a
few win conditions. The best one here is
Shadow Puppeteers. Flashing this in
before your turn comes, you get two
fairies, and we get to attack with a
bunch of four-fours once we untap.
Gravitational Shift is almost
tailor-made for this deck. All of our
flyers are three-ones and will face less
pressure on the ground. And there's of
course Strixhaven Stadium. We can
trigger that win condition fairly
consistently and killing with a game of
Quidditch is just beyond satisfying. And
we're running out. Blue is just awful at
winning with creatures, so we have to be
a bit creative. Now, Kaito here doesn't
win us the game directly, but I mean, it
gives enough value to warrant the three
mana cost. But there's a solid chance
also that we'll be able to ult
immediately after dropping him. And
that's a crazy emblem. We get a swarm of
two-ones every turn for the remainder of
the game. I mean, we can definitely
still lose from that position if we're
challenging bracket four, but it sounds
like a good time either way. And
finally, the most exciting card in the
deck and a lot of my decks nowadays,
Mirror Form. Yeah, all my flying men are
now Hullbreaker Horror, Ancient Copper
Dragon, Terror of the Peaks, Yosei,
Kokusho. Hitting the jackpot with this
card is one thing I look forward to
every game. These, along with some small
pump here and there, will help us close
the games. And we do want some flash
enablers, but not too many. The High
Faerie Trickster is great because it's
also a decent flyer, can help us poke
people to death, and also Teferi. Not
only does he give our creatures flash,
but also blocks our opponents from
interacting with us. So, when we're
ready to win, dropping a Teferi on the
end of turn before we untap can make
sure we get there. And finally, some of
the cheapest counter spells within our
budget. We don't have any other
interaction otherwise, so these counter
spells will help us protect our board
while in a pinch deal with opponents'
win conditions and crap like Elesh Norn.
We're keeping the land simple. The only
one worth mentioning is Horizon of
Progress. There will be times when we're
flooded and unable to keep the pressure
up. Horizon will help us set up for
future turns. Oh, and I almost forgot to
mention one of my favorite inclusions in
Aether Vial. Is the card amazing? No,
but it works in the deck. And there's
just a certain satisfaction of taking,
you know, legacy eternal staples and
making them work in EDH. It almost feels
like a crossover. Now, this deck can be
a bit tricky to play. Imagine an opening
hand like this. Do you drop the one
drops or not? The answer usually is no,
unless you open or you top deck
something like a Coastal Piracy. Then
you can drop them, but otherwise I would
wait for the blue spirit to drop first.
So, ideally in your opening hand you
want some ramp to get our commander out
first before we begin swarming the
board. Unless these one drops come with
a bit more value, like for example,
Faerie Seer is amazing. I would always
drop this early. Even stuff like Silver
Raven and Spyglass Siren, these are okay
to drop. But the rest of the the drops
that don't do anything, there's no need
to curve out. You have a bunch of one
drops. You will be able to drop them.
And once we have the blue spirit out, we
drop as many cards as we can, hopefully
doubling up and tripling up with these
coastal piracy effects. The deck is
fairly explosive and can win games with
a good hand on turn five, turn six. It's
nothing broken, but it's very
consistent. You almost never have a
terrible start. And the deck is not as
much of a glass cannon as it might seem
to be. We are aggressive, but we don't
completely lose relevance by the mid or
late game because a bunch of evasive
fliers can always get in. And with our
win conditions, we can always pose a
threat and we can always rebuild after a
board wipe because we do have a lot of
cards. The commander is a huge target,
but we do have a ton of backup effects
like we mentioned, so we're not exactly
all in commander centric. The deck does
take some practice to play, but once you
understand the sequencing, you
understand how the deck works, it's
fairly straightforward. Now, the list I
covered is $90, but if you play the deck
and you enjoy it enough, you can
definitely do some upgrades. No, not the
flying men, those are perfect and
beautiful. where we can splurge some
money and improve is our counter spells.
Right, we don't have any game changers,
so might as well use those slots on, you
know, the fierce guardianship, the force
of wills. Another slightly more
expensive card I want to try is the
Eldrazi Monument because it's protecting
our board while pumping it. That seems
decent. And with the budget, we can
upgrade our land base a little bit. You
know, it's just more versatility with
stuff like winding canyons, Otawara, and
of course Nykthos can generate a lot of
mana.
But for the most part, these upgrades
are pretty marginal. I don't think
they're core to our game plan. So, I do
think this deck idea is better off as a
budget list. And the money you save, you
can spend on accessories. And speaking
of that, recently I got sponsored by a
brand called Kakapopo TCG and they make
everything. I actually bought some of
their products a while back, but
recently they sent me some sample
products. And this one here is one of my
favorites. It's just simple, elegant,
and it just fits really well with the
overall vibe of magic. Unfortunately, I
don't have an angel deck, but if you do,
this is perfect for you. And this is
their kaiju series with all kinds of
different designs. And the price is
super reasonable for the quality we're
getting here. So, yeah, check out their
site, and if you do, use my discount
code levels, all caps, for 5% off. This
is Jin with Next Level Commander, and
I'll see you in my next video.